let's talk about this uh this first
story real quick and uh let's let's see
what's going on we got this story from
fox news san francisco d.a official says
i'm sorry i i keep i actually i keep
scrolling this up i said this was chess
of bowdoin it's not the d.a oh it's the
d.a official who says crime surge fears
linked to racism it's similar
considering the district attorney is
supposed to be the one that's
prosecuting all this crime
reports of vehicle break-ins are up by
between 100
and 750 in parts of san francisco and
we're seeing stuff like this all over we
got this story from the daily mail
crime is basically legal in san
francisco furious shopper post video of
horde of shoplifters fleeing neiman
marcus totally unchecked with armfuls of
designer bags
so uh we'll just we'll just we'll just
jump in i mean i've been talking about
this stuff for a while i don't want to i
lived in the philadelphia area i don't
want to live there because
there were riots there was a it's not
even about the riots there was one story
where
a guy
barricaded himself inside a building and
started shooting at cops
like i think he shot like five people
and so at a certain point i'm just like
why am i even living in a place like
this yeah but especially over the past
year with crime skyrocketing everywhere
you guys are in miami yeah i'm wondering
what you guys have noticed uh yeah
breaking into cars sounds like wynwood
yeah literally like you go down to party
with your friends or whatever in a cool
spot area yeah you come out their cars
it's open wynwood is uh it's it's
basically like think of it as like our
williamsburg of like uh new york or
brooklyn it's like you know going
through gentrification very similar to
austin a lot of graffiti a lot of artsy
so yeah it's like right there in that
art district area so you know but it's
going that used to be the hood back in
the day so now what's going on is like a
lot of car break-ins a lot of people
getting robbed and everything like that
and philly is like oh he's consistently
in the top five or 10 most dangerous
cities in the u.s man so yeah i guess
like there's like the recurring theme
with all of this is that these cities
are typically run by democrats yes
yes yes yes i don't know how political
you guys get because you talk about data
miami is uh we were the last county to
open yeah after the beer bug stuff you
know what i'm saying yeah yeah we were
the last county because florida was open
for a while but miami-dade was the
slowest we just opened back up maybe
what a month ago month ago so yeah we're
pretty they're pretty that's one of the
craziest things is you had that you have
that county that was like safe democrat
that flipped republican
which county was it was that that was
miami wasn't it was that north of miami
is it miami-dade it might have been
broward broward is that one area that's
like it's like i think it might have
been yeah
yeah because
miami data is typically always blue but
uh i wouldn't be surprised if broward
like went red for a bit because broward
is like a lot more diverse than south
florida well it is south florida but
it's much more diverse in miami-dade
yeah it was my
27th
27th district and 27th 26th that was
crazy because they uh they were saying
that
it was safe democrat it wasn't going to
change
but there's like i guess the main theme
of the story that we're going on is
when you look at i think san diego is
run by republicans they're not in the
top 10 for crime even in the top 10
biggest cities so i don't i don't know
if what your guy's opinion on this san
diego is great man i like san diego i'm
not a fan of california but san diego i
do like so nice just in general for like
the crime we're seeing
honestly it's like in miami um for crime
it's kind of like how to put this it's
more in the party scene i would say this
like let's say you're going out friends
right you meet a girl guys are getting
like finesse from girls like for example
you bring to your house you know you
have a great time but then you wake up
your stuff is gone that's the problem
i'm all the time right we're miami think
about it we're you know party capital
and then just being a regular regular
civilian you know you're walking around
whatever
a certain area is obviously still not
safe but i would say more it's like car
break-ins you know guys gonna finesse
from girls and then also you know even
behind the scenes there's like um you
know theft with scammers you know people
putting does it feel like it's going up
um i'll say this um miami beach has
definitely changed significantly over
the past you know 10 15 years you know
ever since uh for me what i noticed the
trigger point was right around 2008 when
florida started getting on the map with
dj khaled and little wayne and all these
rappers like really like representing
the south florida area and then it
brought more tourism more traffic to
miami because a lot of people think
miami beach like oh ocean drive they
think that's miami no that's miami beach
yeah but miami beach now it's it could
be ratchet at times like memorial day
weekend you don't want to be there so um
but yeah there there's a lot of crime in
miami beach because you know it draws a
certain crowd there on certain types of
events and then yeah a lot of fights
shootings robberies you know in miami
beach quite a bit i would say the main
tourist broward and miami beach because
we're in brickell downtown so we're kind
of like in a safe area so to speak but
yeah like crazy like you know and then
downtown miami has like all the homeless
people yeah like all the homeless people
in concentrated downtown
yeah dude it's yo okay get this right so
i came here five years ago to miami
right from barbados and
downtown brickell was kind of like okay
open area not too much people were there
not to be homeless now it's like overrun
but you know the pandemic all this stuff
happens people are out of jobs that's
where they go rickle is like the
manhattan of miami if i was to give
people like an example of what it is
it's like the financial district it's
clean it's nice like you know they've
been really working on making it nice
because it used to be when people came
to miami they would go to miami beach
immediately they would never go into the
city right like you actually you would
never go into the city unless you worked
but now you know the city's becoming
more tourist friendly they're trying to
compete with miami beach that's why
wynwood is coming up the design district
brickell has its home
its own scene and everything else like
that but so it's like
it's fixing but yeah i mean there's
definitely like a lot of scammers in
miami a lot of girls rob dudes people
don't know it's just that the guys don't
report it to the customer you know what
i'm saying yeah i lived in miami for a
little bit uh i was in by homestead
actually where they were that famous
child detention migrant facility or
whatever
and we had uh one crazy thing happened
the neighbors warned us that there were
some home invasions and people were shot
and killed and so i think this is why
this is what explains a lot of like you
know florida gets a republican governor
ron desantis everybody loves the guy you
know and they're saying he might run for
president or maybe he'll be vice
president who knows but when i was there
this is a story i often tell people i
was at a trump rally talking to people
about this because uh you know this was
this is back in the day or it was like
six years ago
there was there were some home invasions
a guy was in his shower
and he heard noise downstairs like
rustling so he walks downstairs in his
towel and then two guys see him and then
just one guy just shoots him in the
chest kills him and this is this is like
40 miles west of miami so it's like not
that far away okay and you know so i was
talking to people in the neighborhood
about they're like you got to be really
careful you know you i hope you have
guns and we were like we didn't have any
guns we're in the middle of nowhere but
we weren't armed or anything like that
we had like an air pressure rifle
and so then talking to talking to these
people a lot of them were latino
immigrants a lot of them were cuban yeah
and they said oh yeah those like we're
talking about neighbors about it and
they're like oh yeah those guys oh yeah
they killed it i think they caught them
they were illegal immigrants who like
were ransacking houses west of miami
where it's like there's no cops it's
pitch black it's like farm houses oh
probably unincorporated
homestead is no man's land
and there's nothing out there it's very
cheap over there too so i get it yeah
there's an air force base but that's
about it yeah but that's that that to me
was why not like
when the people i see the trump flags
everywhere and i was talking at rallies
talking to people at rallies i was like
oh
now i get it like this is these are the
stories that they're hearing all the
time that's why they're very concerned
about illegal immigration that's why
they're very concerned about how against
the guns and things like that
but anyway i digress you know i want to
ask you guys like how do you how do you
manage to do a podcast underwater you
know
oh i heard i heard miami we're thinking
yeah we're sinking every day bro we had
a building that has just collapsed
south beach
so apparently the building had a very
bad structure it was had some issues
going on but they didn't they never
fixed it so they were told ahead of time
hey guys this building is under some you
know some you know issues
as soon as possible but they never did
it and then what happened was i think we
had like a lot of rain a lot of like um
what what was it was like a fish or
something like that yeah i mean the
thing about miami is like a lot of the
buildings were built you know on the
back of
you know the cocaine era you know so
it's like they're not necessarily like
miami was built on the back of like
narco trafficking so let's be honest
about it so like you know they like it
and it's because i'm a real estate
investor in miami too yeah it's not
uncommon for them to be breaking all
kinds of codes and violations when
you're like looking at real estate
property in miami so i would not be
surprised if that building was uh didn't
pass certain regulations and it might
have like you know collapse on itself
yeah so somebody just greased some palms
yeah
you put some money over there
yeah you know like hey i gotta dump this
money in somewhere bro like somewhere so
real estate but imagine you're in your
home all of a sudden oh yeah that's
crazy yeah yeah there's so many
buildings in miami like that so who
knows my might be on the water who
really knows what if your podcast you
know what if like you're building your
own just like dude yeah it's bro who
knows because i'll tell you this we're
high up when it rains
when brickell uh when when it rains
really bad and brickle like it does go
underwater like there's flood there's
like cuddles everywhere cars are driving
through where like it's like a imagine
you're at a lake and it's the city it's
that crazy so it's bad is it really
sinking though
or is it like because when i was there i
remember i went down to miami beach one
day and there was like a couple inches
of water just in the street
and they said oh it's because miami's
sinking but other people told me it's
been like this forever it's like it's
sea level so it rains and then like
there's nowhere to drain the water so it
just like is in the streets so i'm
wondering how much of it's political
because here's the thing they're saying
that you know the water levels are going
to rise climate change and all that but
you still got all these investors buying
up property all across miami yeah that's
my question dude why these millionaires
dumping money into a property that may
go underwater so i'm thinking they must
be doing something behind the scenes to
stop the you know not only that like
me and fresh are both involved in real
estate too and uh the market in miami
right now is hot man like these these uh
if you guys are trying to buy a miami
man this is going to be expensive
because these new york investors they're
moving down in roads canadians russia
yeah china from massachusetts new york
connecticut the northeast in general are
moving down there in droves because
they're looking at like okay what did
the beer bug teach us okay well now you
can work from home you don't necessarily
need to be tied to a certain location to
be able to do work and commute in so why
are you gonna pay three four five six
thousand dollars to live in a closet in
new york city when you can go down to
florida warm all year no state income
tax and for a lot of people that don't
know this
florida is actually fairly cheap to live
in miami is actually a cheap city to
live in you can get a one bedroom
apartment in brickell which is in
manhattan miami for 2000 a month or less
you would never find that in manhattan
nope
my my friend had a had a had a place in
brickell
over overlooking like the bay and they
had two they had two pools for residents
a salt water pool and a fresh water pool
yeah not that expensive
that's like super nice places people
think miami is expensive but here's the
thing
it's expensive if you park
miami since so many people come to party
miami beach it's expensive but if you
actually live in the city of miami not
that bad and if you want to avoid sea
level you can go to wynwood and that's
above sea level it is hello investors
that's where they go to invest by
property that's going to blow up soon
yeah i'm sorry go ahead no i was going
to say man i think a lot of people are
moving down there because of freedom
facts yeah i mean you had texas in
florida saying you don't got to wear
masks you can do whatever you want like
life is normal here yeah that's why
people i think oh i think a lot of
people moved to florida so uh our friend
luke for instance you know he was on the
show lukowski for for a couple months
and then he's like i'm leaving i'm going
to florida and he was like you should
come with and i'm like bro we can't just
go to
we went to florida
i don't know what he's doing now it's a
great state man you should come man
i lived in florida the problem is you
can't go outside
what the humidity
humidity it's like it's a hundred
degrees with maximum humidity and it's
monsooning half the time i lived in
i'll take warm weather because i grew up
in connecticut so i grew up in the
northeast i went to college in boston
i'm very familiar with new england and
northeast in general i lived in new york
city i've lived in philly and it's just
like man i'll take that hot weather over
cold weather any day man like but that's
just me some people like the season
changing but like for me it's like it's
cheaper it's warmer the girls are hotter
you know listen i will say this though
here's my prediction
nevada florida and texas are going to
see huge migration of new and uh why is
that
because uh they all don't have state
income tax and they're all a lot of
people are escaping major cities that
are expensive las vegas for la
uh a lot of people from new york are
coming down to florida florida and then
um texas everyone's just going to texas
because texas is a fantastic place if i
wasn't in florida i'd be in texas
houston you could buy a beautiful home
for three hundred thousand dollars
uh you know it's it's uh texas is a very
self-sufficient state gas is cheap food
is cheap they make a lot of their own
stuff very self-sufficient say hell if
they wanted to leave the united states
they could don't they have that on paper
somewhere i think they do yeah so um the
only thing that sucks is like you know
houston traffic is awful and you need a
car but texas a great place to be so i
think those three states in the next
five to ten years you guys are going to
see an explosion because now people are
seeing i don't have to be domain
dependent on where i am to like work i
can work remotely so if you're going to
work remotely why not pay less taxes and
be in a warmer better area there are
there are some rumors i haven't looked
into this that west virginia is also
trying to get rid of their their west
virginia is trying to get rid of their
income tax at least at a certain level i
don't know if they're actually going to
do it or not i haven't looked into it
but a lot of people in west virginia are
talking about it so i like it out here
man you know uh it's close enough to the
east coast couple hours to philly a
couple hours to you know you well not a
couple hours but you can head down to
miami difficult dc's right there yeah
and uh you're allowed to have guns
you know you can you got big big open
spaces and i like snowboarding you know
periodically maybe once or twice i don't
want to go crazy with it but winter is
nice yeah new hampshire i would say new
hampshire is also good as well for
people that want to stay in new england
and still be able to get that experience
because there's no standing with tax in
new hampshire either and you're just a
hop skipping away from uh
massachusetts you know if you want to go
to boston or springfield or anything
like that regarding like coastal cities
getting going underwater i think what
happens when that does happen is it
happens in jolts because if the if the
ice caps melt there will be like a rise
in in water but what happens is when the
ice is removed from the earth the earth
rises where that ice used to be and
earth elsewhere on the planet goes down
so like it will literally sink so not
only does the water level rise but the
earth sinks wait wait wait wait you're
saying the water when ice caps melt and
just disappear all in the day if there's
like a firestorm and all the ice caps
are gone all that land rises where the
ice used to be compressing it goes up
and so earth on other parts of the
planet go down when that when that land
goes up so the ice caps are removed part
of earth will sink hold on bro and
that's in addition to the water rushing
well a lot of times climate change
happens in jolts it doesn't happen the
northern ice caps aren't on land you've
got green land which is on land
and octagon is antarctica basically
uh depends on depending on your source
antarctica is gaining ice in some areas
maybe losing ice but if it were to lose
its ice that that that's you would see
land sink as well as water go up so i
like are like the tectonic plates
floating on water are you saying it
depends on what theory you look at if
you look at the expanding earth theory
there are no tectonics i don't think
expanding earth theory is real i think
we should go deep on
this
i don't know man we're talking about
investing in real estate and everything
yeah well land's sinking i don't think
it's going to sink i don't i think
buying it is a short-term
considered high-risk investment when
it's not
but i just think it's weird that i watch
this video where a guy made a really
good point he's like all these people
are coming out claiming that you know
climate change is going to wipe
everything out it's going to the water
level is going to rise 20 feet and there
are and all these rich people are buying
up beachfront property in miami like
what look either they're expecting it
not to happen or they're lying see
that's the question here why are they
buying these million dollar homes right
on the water something's come
something's up here they know something
something that we don't know they have
to maybe they're atlanti and they can
breed underwater yeah that's probably
absolutely yeah but i'm seeing now i
mean they're putting like these pillars
in the water i don't know what they do
but it's most like stabilize the the
i don't know what it is but they're
putting pillars in the water i don't
know like wave breaks are they breaking
the waves it's uh i don't know what it
does bro
what i think honestly is that yeah these
new yorkers these new york investors
have so much money that like even if the
place was to flood or whatever it is
they can fix the damages like they can
they're buying it at such a low cost
that even buying it at that cost and
fixing the damage is going to be cheaper
than buying a piece of property in new
york like i grew up in brooklyn new york
right like uh and i uh
and uh
right off church avenue right as a kid
like from zero to nine years old then i
moved that property i went and like
looked at it it's worth like two million
dollars now and it's like just like a
little crappy apartment like building
and it's like worth two million dollars
now so it's like new york uh real estate
you can't even get in the game unless
you have millions so it's like oh i can
go to florida and buy like a triplex or
a quadplex or whatever or maybe even an
apartment building for under a million
yeah i'm gonna do that but as an
investor well hold on some of these
firms are probably just getting fed
money for free it's just they just get
loans from the banks they don't care
about what what's what's the worst case
scenario if you buy this property and 30
is under water whatever bankruptcy you
walk away why do they care is it is it
blackstone is doing that yeah black rock
and black stone right yeah black black
stone i think bought up a company that
that does this that buys properties and
rents them out and then i think black
rock was the one that was buying up all
the properties themselves mm-hmm i don't
know i got i got there's like two
different companies i know right it's
annoying i'm just saying if i'm if i'm
i'm an investor a smart investor i don't
put money into something that might lose
money so i'm just thinking from from my
point of view hey i'm investigators no
sea level problems i don't know yeah but
i'm just what i've come to realize is
like these new york investors they're
not even getting good cash on cash
returns like that they're barely
breaking ten percent and they're still
doing the deal so that tells me that
they just have a bunch of money they
need to get rid of it
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel
tim cast youtube.comcastio
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you